something absolutely sickening happened and
Republican senators are mostly providing cover
to Donald Trump over it, which is that Donald
Trump claimed that U S military members who
have suffered traumatic brain injuries and
concussions have headaches that he doesn't
consider to be very serious. Donald Trump
previously insisted that no one was hurt when
Iran launched missile attacks on bases in
Iraq that housed us troops back on January
8th we covered that extensively when it happened.
This is not true. 34 troops have been diagnosed
with either concussions or traumatic brain
injuries. After those attacks, Donald Trump
insisted nobody was hurt. We were first told,
well 11 people were pulled out for concussions
or brain injuries. That number has since climbed
to 34 military service members suffering traumatic
brain injuries or concussions. And Donald
Trump is just downplaying the reports of the
injuries as headaches and that nothing is
very serious. And there are some members of
the military that are absolutely furious while
there are others as well as many Republican
senators who were saying, no, no, I mean Donald
Trump is fine. And what he's saying, here's
Donald Trump being asked about this at the
world economic forum in Davos, Switzerland
a few days ago,
repeatedly to American that after Iran retaliated
for the Solomanis strike, no Americans were
injured. We now know at least 11 U S service
men were airlifted from Iraq. Can you explain
the
discrepancy? No. A, I heard that they had
headaches and a couple of other things, but
I would say, yeah, and I can report it is
not very serious, not very serious traumatic
brain injury. Uh, they told me about it numerous
days. Lady had ha have to ask the department
of defense. No, I don't consider them very
serious injuries relative to other injuries
that I've seen. I've seen what Iran has done
with their roadside bombs to our trips. I've
seen people with no legs and with no arms.
I've seen people that were horribly, horribly
injured in that area, that war. Uh, in fact,
many cases put those bombs put there by solid
Maney who's no longer with us. Uh, I consider
them to be really bad injuries. No, I do not
consider that to be bed injuries. Now, Donald
bone spurs, Trump calls traumatic brain injuries
headaches and just doesn't see them as a serious
thing. Now, you know, the, the fallacy of
you can always come up with something worse.
Like, okay, you could have a traumatic brain
injury and lose a leg. All right, well, yeah,
that would be worse. We can imagine something
worse. But the completely lackadaisical nature
of Donald Trump brushing this off as not serious
as a traumatic brain injuries can be completely
debilitating. They can be completely disabling
for someone. They can lead to suicide. Trump
wouldn't know about it. Of course, someone
who figured out how to avoid military service
in Vietnam, and by the way, I don't fault
him for it. If I were at risk of being drafted
to that insanely pointless and misguided war,
I also would've tried to get out of serving
in it, but I wouldn't be going around downplaying
traumatic brain injuries as not very serious
because somebody else had a more serious injury
at some other time.
Does anybody in my audience remember the George
W. Bush days where if you even suggested anything
but endless unflinching support for not just
the troops, but at the time it was if you
didn't support the mission in Iraq, you were
called an anti American trader by these right
wingers. What happened to that? This guy does
not care about the men and women who serve
the Sola. Amani assassination was politically
convenient to Trump. He thinks, I mean it
may be, it may not be. He may be right. We
don't know. The followup effects aren't a
concern. The injuries caused aren't a concern
period. It's a world of Donald Trump. And
in that world, traumatic brain injuries are
headaches. Soldiers who aren't captured and
held as pow. He doesn't prefer. Remember he
said about John McCain, he prefers war heroes
who don't get captured. Um, PTSD happens because
some soldiers just aren't strong enough as
Donald Trump has previously said, but his
bone spurs were serious and valid as a reason
to get the skip the war altogether that many
other people his age simply didn't have a
choice about, weren't able to appeal to a
wealthy doctor willing to write a note to
get Donald Trump out of serving in Vietnam.
Another aspect of this is that Donald Trump
also in addition to not caring about the troops,
doesn't understand brain injuries. I mean,
we could say even if he understood them, he
still wouldn't care. But Donald Trump knows
nothing about brain injuries and how they
can manifest causing depression leading to
suicide, making it so someone simply cannot
work or live a normal life. This guy knows
nothing and you have to be really careful
about anybody who hangs their hat on. I support
the troops back during the Iraq days, supporting
the troops met, supporting the war in Iraq.
Now as a progressive who cares about people?
To me, supporting the troops means you don't
send the troops in to fight political battles
for your personal benefit. Or in George w
Bush's case because his dad wasn't able to
get it done or whatever the case may be, you
make sure that they have healthcare and workforce
reintegration when they come home.
Uh, now support the troops under Trump. I
don't even know what it means to support the
troops under Trump. I think it means support.
Whatever it is Donald Trump wants to do with
the troops for his political gain. I don't
even know if that phrase has meaning in 2020
under Donald Trump, but disgusting and even
more disgusting that they're Republicans who
are defending
what Donald Trump said.